um
thank you
the organizers and thank you for coming
in
uh
today i'll be talking about
retrospective search this is how we coin
it although the
idea is kind of relatively simple
uh you want to talk about
searching for something and the goal is
to
find that something that is going to be
best for you
and then just pick that one up what
could be an idea
maybe we're trying to find the
uh
efficacy of a drug and we're trying to
increase the dosage gradually until we
find that you know what
at some point maybe it became too
dangerous for the patients and we go
back to the most
most difficult
level or maybe it could be the case that
i'm trying to tweak around the model
until i actually get to something that i
can solve around but i'm doing
incremental changes where i can get a
solution
another search would be
if uh we were to actually try to search
for gold
what you would get is a a mineral vein
that will be dictated by the department
of agriculture and you just go searching
through that mineral vein until you by
digging small exploratory wells
where at some point you're going to
decide okay i think this is where i'm
going to develop the whole actual
mind and then exploit that mind forever
same is true for policy
experimentation maybe you want to start
with i don't know casual fridays move a
little bit more to casual fridays and
semi-casual thursdays and then
eventually decide halfway casual is the
best one for you and finally it could be
something as simple as online shopping
or real life shopping for this example
i woke up i walked down the street where
i'm gonna get the
my
bagel and coffee i walk down the street
until i find the place that i'm going to
like which was a bagel street cafe and
then i decide that's the place i'm going
to get come back purchase from there and
now i'm happy enough to actually talk to
you and fair enough to talk to you
so
there are two main features that we want
to kind of highlight within the searches
the first is correlation because
if i'm
digging down through a
mineral vein
how much gold i find is kind of
indicative of how much i'm going to find
immediately in the adjacent plot
or if i'm looking for restaurants at the
street there is going to be some sort of
neighborhood effects that's going to
tell me what kind of restaurants that
i'll be seeing
if you think for example online shopping
i'm going to look through let's say a
clicker on amazon and then amazon is
going to tell me customers have also
looked to something similar which i
expected to be a clicker and not
something else entirely
second thing is i'm going to also choose
my speed i can try to rush through the
street to get my bagel or i could
actually slowly leisurely take a walk
and decide which one i'm going to
actually pick and both of them are going
to
be decisive in the eventual outcome that
i'm going to choose
so our question is how should we conduct
a search like this
what pace should i be going through and
what am i going to eventually pick and
how i'm going to stop
so correlation we're going to actually
borrow from steve's
idea and we're going to think about the
set of outcomes to be a realized
brownian pet so the street is over there
i don't know what's in there there are
some qualities over
the restaurants that i might see that
i'll eventually pick too
and i'm going to assume our search is
going to be incremental this is
admittedly a restriction because uh
maybe i actually take an uber i realized
that half of the street is not relevant
for me but for some other applications
it's going to be a little more natural
for fda it's going to actually require
you to test the
dosage in given increments if you're
doing mineral exploration you're
actually going to have to move to
your digging machine incrementally it's
not going to teleport from one place to
another
and then
the
search speed we are going to capture by
actually choosing costly variance this
allows us to think about
uh variance in two terms i'm going to be
mostly using the term speed
in terms of
actual speed but another way to think
about it is actually my breadth of
instantaneous search too it could be
that when i'm looking for a clicker how
many holes i go through of the google
could be my instantaneous various
variance joints as well
and finally we're going to assume
obviously perfect recall after i
searched through the street i'm not
going to forget what i saw at the
beginning of the street i mean i might
but we're going to assume the decision
maker is not going to do that and
they're going to go back and pick the
best choice that they will see
turns out we are going to actually have
a u-shaped search speed now that you
might seem a little bit odd at this
point
that you is going to be related to the
breaks we might have in the search
and there are two breaks that are
relevant for our search one is going to
be a breakthrough where we are going to
find
a new best outcome so i saw one bagel
shop and then i found a new bagel shop
that's going to be a breakthrough for me
and then the second one is going to be a
breakdown where i say you know what i
ended up in some weird neighborhood
maybe i shouldn't be actually going
forward and then i go back and pick up
my foot from somewhere else that's going
to be our breakdown
and our search speed is going to be
u-shaped
in terms of where our breakthrough and
breakdown
levels are and notice these are going to
be things that we're going to be
carrying over as we see more stuff
and the stopping rule is going to be a
relatively simple stopping boundary
which means we are actually not going to
i'm going to use the term boundary
instead of a stopping region
because stopping boundary i will say
that once we see something that's bad
enough that we are going to stop
that's distinctly different than
satisficing behavior what for example a
banded model or like independent search
would tell you but once i see something
good enough i'm going to stop because in
reality we see that
you don't actually see something good
enough and stop you usually actually
decide i don't know sampling five prices
or sampling different restaurants and go
back to the best one you might have seen
and then i'll also talk about the
application given that the solution
would be a little uh
is going to be surprisingly simple
we'll be able to actually embed the
search model into a contracting
environment instead of me searching for
a restaurant i'll actually hire someone
pay them a wage and give them a
commission to cons to do the search on
my behalf
this of course is going to
uh be the case for example you want to
sell your house or you want to be
buying a piece of art
where or you're actually just trying to
find a new innovation where the
university is paying you a wage and
eventually they'll get a chunk out of
the new patent you get those kind of
contracts we will be able to
characterize completely with this
methodology
now in terms of literature well some of
the literature is actually already in
here
it's related to ponderos problems
obviously because there is some search
and we're searching until we find
something can we pick the best option
and there is some relation to
experimentation although there is not
exactly experimentation going on we are
not learning about some unknown
attribute and trying to make tests about
learning about it this is actually some
realized brownian path where we're
trying to find the maxima for ourselves
and that already is going to be somewhat
related to the optimal stopping of a
diffusion literature in math so
this fit i'm going to
leave to steve to talk about a little
bit but
to me at least he is one of the
forefathers of this
actual modeling choice of capturing
correlation in search models
so today i'll be first talking about the
model and give you the optimal policy
and then i'll be describing the
contracting and conclude
now
with the idea in mind let's try to
actually formalize this a little bit
we're doing our search in continuous
time
you might want to try to think of it as
a discrete version of
searching through a random walk as well
if you want although there will be some
gaps in that idea where you'll lose some
tractability if you go that way
so the
basic set of prospects is there is a
street and i'm running it speed
sigma t through that street
i'm going to assume for now we start
from zero expectation because that's
also my fallout option i i need to eat
something which has usually this year if
i don't eat anything
uh at every point in time our agent is
going to choose their speed or you can
think of it as ambition or breadth and
we are going to assume that agent cannot
stop
because if you're just idling you're
letting time run by while your hunger is
accumulating
and cost of actually walking faster is
going to be increasing it's going to be
twice differentiable and convex
sometimes i'm going to assume it's low
comics to give unique predictions
although it's not necessary
and the perfect recall part
from whatever i have seen so far until
this point
the best option
is going to be the maximum that i keep
track of
again we need to somehow start with the
initial point and there's no harm in
assuming that m0 is equal to zero so i
didn't come with a cup noodles in my bag
just to give a little bit of a picture
if this is the
for example utils or the payoffs i would
get from the different restaurants
industry there is no
uh this is the pre-realized path of the
street
somewhere down i don't remember the name
of it
then the maximum has some peculiar
properties if you look at it first of
all
this is a graphical glitch maximum is
actually
almost surely constant most of the time
it's going to be constant when you
really zoom on in here it's going to
look like this inside there is a
second obviously it's increasing which
is going to be kind of useful for us to
think about the problem
one thing also about maximum that's kind
of nice is that if we actually use a
constant search speed without an extra e
then the
maximum is proportional to sigma
so this kind of allows us to have a good
interpretation and compare it to for
example exponential search models if
you're doing exponential search in labor
you see that if you increase your speed
or effort
every outcome you're going to get is
going to be better and they're going to
be potentially coming at a faster rate
here what we end up with is that if i'm
exerting more effort
then i do expect to find something
that's really better and that's
proportional to the sigma that i have
but not everything is going to be better
i'm really just searching with a wider
variance
second thing is even though the
uh
maximum process by itself it is a rather
weird process that's almost
uh constant everywhere if i look through
arbitrary breakthroughs those are going
to actually happen really with an
exponential distribution
so
we're kind of getting that
good news or breakthroughs are coming
through some exponential rate but we're
not assuming the underlying thing is
actually exponential and independent
from past for what we have seen before
and the
goal of our agent is relatively simple
our agent is trying to
maximize the maximum that they will
encounter
that's going to be discounted by some
discount rate
and as they continue their search their
accumulating costs until they actually
stop again discounted with the discount
rate
subject to the actual search process
that we have
is
just determined by our speed and the
maximum is just as we have described
we might put a utility function for m as
well which i'm going to hopefully talk
at all the way to the end
but for the basic premise we're going to
assume that
the process we are searching through is
really capturing in terms of futile so
we are going to avoid risk aversion for
now
our agent has two choices to make it a
given time the first is obviously tau
and then the second is the sigma t
where sigma t obviously has to be an
adapted process tau has to be an adapted
stopping rule that we can pick through
and they are also connected with each
other too so
we are doing
control and stopping jointly at the same
time
now to think about
the assumptions we made
with independence recall is
unimportant
actually what you're going to do is
you're going to set a level and then the
moment you see something about that
level you stop
very easy but
not really good with empirical evidence
of how people have done the research
uh
and it's going to be satisficing
behavior
if we do not have recall
then actually we're searching through
brownian motion that has no drift
without recall
i'm paying costs to have an expected
increase of util of zero i'm never gonna
do that so recall should actually be the
case that it makes it
sensible for me to go
continue the search
if there is actually drift which we
didn't assume where actually we think
that the street is getting better as we
go along
then i either stop immediately or search
indefinitely it's not going to make a
lot of
difference you can also add risky
version without recall if you had risky
version without recall then again
you might still have a simple decision
of when to stop again we will also still
require some positive drift
we're assuming
no drift
for
the relevance of applications first is
if i'm doing some sort of research for
if i'm just
doing a think of this as really
generating ideas and the brownian motion
is capturing the new idea with sigma the
amount of tweak i do to my idea at a
given point in time
if there is drift
then that means mere passage of time is
going to give me better results that
means if i actually look at
for example
amazon look long enough then it's going
to show me their best product it's not
going to actually show it to me from the
get-go so just i should pass through the
first few ones
ahead
second you might think about me actually
searching about the ordered list of uh
tests if i already know something far
into the future is better then i should
just start from there not from somewhere
in the beginning
and we actually
can accommodate fixed drift as well it
just makes the analysis a lot more
cumbersome it's not that
it's impossible to incorporate it's just
a little odd and
uh makes our calculations pretty bad
if we were to only add the drift then we
get peskier's other paper the first one
was the optimal stopping of the maximum
this is the optimal stoving
optimal control of drift the result is a
bang bang result it's not terribly
interesting you either maximize your
drift or minimize your drift and that's
all you have
uh
and again effort is increasing all
outcomes if you're controlling drift
whereas we want to capture that
effort is actually increasing the best
outcome you will see as opposed to
everything that you see
okay so let's get back to the problem
uh we were talking about the strategy of
being composed of two elements the
chosen choice of search and the stopping
time and both in principle might depend
on the entire history of
uh mt xt and even calendar time if you
want to do it
but
first let's make our stopping rule a
little easier
if at any time it's optimal to stop at
the m and x
then if the current realization is lower
with the maximum being higher
with the maximum being the same i should
also stop
it's quite intuitive i have the same
fallback option i'm in everest part of
the town
so
if i was stopping at a better option
i'll stop at the same point second
if it's optimal to start the problem at
0 0
then it's optimal to continue at a at a
new maxima as well because what i have
done is i have added m to my pocket and
i just restarted my problem all together
so that means actually it's never
optimal
to stop at a new maximum
then the only way we are going to
actually stop is when we something bad
enough in terms of research it's going
to be the case that
i'm doing this
drug research and i see it's getting
better and better
for my patients i'm not going to stop
i'm only going to stop that if somebody
is going to end up dying then i'm like
okay maybe this is really not going to
work out i should go back and go use an
appropriate dosage for these
and a simple way to represent
a
[Music]
stopping rule of this form is just
assuming there is some sort of
continuous function such that when the
current observation is below
this g of m we are going to stop
we do show that this function has to be
continuous but it's kind of easy if you
think about it everything is smooth
there cannot be any jumps in there
now that we have a function let's try to
actually depict what it looks like a
simple function
if g of m is m minus 2 that's what it
looks in terms of
m versus g of m
axis but in reality it's going to tell
me that if i have a realized path then
this g of m is actually also following
the realized path of g as well
m as well and i'm going to stop for
example at this point whereas if i were
using m minus 3
over this path i would not have stopped
if this were a more complicated function
then these differences would be changing
as we go along it's constant in here
but that's all it's going to change it's
still going to be some sort of shifting
of the maximum function we see
so
now that we have the basic model
let's actually be
describe what the optimal speed is
because it's going to be quite easy
if we have a
continuous stopping boundary then the
optimal search speed
is identified uniquely by this
uh equality
let's try to actually ignore this
elephant in here and
look at the right hand side and the
left-hand side
this is telling me that the optimal
search speed
is dependent on both the
level of the costs as well as the
margins
this kind of makes sense because if i'm
changing my
speed
i'm changing both how much my marginal
cost is going through
and for whatever my optimal stopping
rule is i'm also changing how fast i'm
going to that stopping rule
in terms of time
i'm playing that
c
whereas in terms of
increase in speed i'm paying that c
prime
there now where is this
uh creature coming from this creature is
coming from the fact that we had the
bricks right
and this is actually the breaks we have
i'm either going to try to reach a new
breakthrough
or i'm going to try to reach
a breakdown because if you really think
about it the search i'm doing
at an arbitrary point is
going to not change my maximum it's
always almost the same
all i'm doing is kind of accumulating
costs until i reach a breakthrough or
break down
so the goal is to somehow
capture how that
is going to affect us and that is going
to tell why we get that u-shape again
as i'm kind of approaching for example a
new breakthrough
then i'm thinking you know what my
maximum is about to change
then the expected time i'm going to
spend
trying to reach a breakthrough is not
going to be
that high i can try to speed up
on the other hand if i'm somewhere smack
in the middle of the breakthrough and
break down
then i'm thinking
well the problem is pretty stale i'm
either going to break down or i'm going
to break i'm going to do a breakthrough
right now if i speed up it's not going
to help me because i also have
discounting to take care of
instead i should potentially try to save
on my local costs right now where i'm
going to try to slow down in that part
yeah the question is about the previous
slide is g of n always there minus a
constant or no
uh
it will turn out to be so
in general uh it needs a proof
uh though long as you have recently
tried the videos
now here comes the part if c is low come
x then this is monotone
then you actually have a unique solution
it's obviously installation condition
there could be many other conditions
that you can come up with that will
guarantee you the solution here
and another thing to realize is if there
is no discounting
we get this part
then
our search speed is going to be constant
and independent of the entire thing that
we have seen
so if you're doing some sort of search
where discounting really doesn't matter
like me searching through
for a bagel
it's a relatively short amount of time
i'm not gonna i have significant
discounting over there then my optimal
speed is constant
and completely independent of whatever i
have seen as far as
the options and what the best and the
current options are
and this bit
is actually something you can really
just open up your
uh handbook of
brownian motion and find it in closed
form because it's
a standard brownian motion escaping
there is no more speed in there
and it has a relatively ugly form
but
it's at least something we know so
that
equality is actually uniquely pinning
down the entire search speed
and
one thing that
again that i have said is that it's
going to be constant when there is no
discounting another thing that i should
also say is that if you look at the
formula beforehand
you will see that expected discounted
time is also approaching
one as you approach the boundaries so
that means
actually even if we have discounting
towards the boundaries we will have the
same speed as if we have no discount
so
what does this mean if we look at this
weird clown face looking thing we see
that
no matter what our discounting is it's
only going to have an impact when we are
away from the boundaries and it's a
mechanical effect it's just saying that
the relative path is not really saying
much
the difference is purely how fast i'm
able to escape from this breakthrough
breakdown cycle
okay
and we see that this is also somehow uh
relevant to some behavioral uh
observations you might have which is the
goal gradient hypothesis where you're
going to exert greater effort when
approaching a goal or when approaching
some kind of breakdown
instead of a behavioral explanation here
we end up with a analytical explanation
if you buy the assumptions of the model
so far
on the other hand if we think about the
constant search speed
uh that is also pretty
evident that you can see
uh many companies do not fluctuate their
research and development expenditures
regardless of what they are actually
finding through and in fact in again
mineral prospecting it's one of the
award-winning procedures you might
actually hit
a very promising rain or a very
promising exploratory
uh dig or a very bad
exploratory dick until you run through
the vein and until you give up you're
supposed to actually dig at the same
depth
according to
so
let's try to get a little bit of a
better intuition the
if you're kind of looking at the speed
it is really kind of we're looking at
distance in time
so if there is no discounting
this is really how much i'm paying per
second and this is how fast i'm running
through and in fact if you maximize this
you end up with the sigma zero that we
end up in here
it's kind of a
misleading intuition over there though
because
that is going to minimize cost per
distance in time at every point
the idea is you're trying to actually
minimize the time to escape if you have
no discounting minimizing your cost per
distance is also minimizing your time to
escape that's why this is kind of
misleading but easy to see where the
formula comes from
now let's think about the stopping
boundary and the stopping boundary is
exactly what you have said it's going to
be identified by a constant where
it's going to be m minus dr where this
tr is
going to solve
this particular
equation
it might look ugly but if you like
squint enough you'll see that this is
the expected discounted time again the
brownian motion escaping through
and d0 is actually showing up because
our speed at the boundaries were
actually independent of the discounting
we had
so
it's a closed form something you can
also do calculus on
it looks very bad because it has sins in
it uh cnh and
cross h in it but
i think it's good enough for an optimal
solution optimal stopping problem
uh one thing we want to kind of also
mention is that when you have a boundary
that's actually linear
it's called a drawdown
i'm going to
observe the outcomes and one whenever i
fall dr below then i'm going to decide
that it is time for me to stop it's as
if i have drawn down of a constant
distance hence the name throw down in
there
uh
as r increases dr is going to decrease
which is
uh saying that if you're getting more
patient your drawdown is decreasing so
you're going to actually
demanding a better and better
path
and again so the picture i have shown
you was another random picture it was
actually some optimal solution from what
we could have seen before
another thing is when the discount
factor does not exist then the drawdown
is extremely simple
why is that true the intuition is also
quite simple if we actually just push
our
current state and maximum by a constant
amount
then the problem hasn't changed we
actually
saved everything in there which means
the gap has to be constant
but then the moment we know the gap has
to be constant
then we can use the speed solution we
have to try to actually pin down what
that gap is and that is very dependent
on how fast we are going so that is kind
of the addition you will see from in the
regular optimal stopping literature your
speed is given to you whereas here your
speed is actually governing your entire
stopping rule as well as your uh payoff
okay
now let's think about allowing for
uh
risk evaluation
one particular thing is that
the
speed func the speed equation that i
have shown you
is completely independent of the
shape of the utility function
so
in the sense that if i'm given the same
drawdown rule
that's a big if though
then the speed is not going to have any
uh the
utility function is not going to have
impact
and the idea is simple
i'm still trying to escape
and if i'm escaping i'm only
accumulating costs remember our utility
was going to come to the maximum not to
the cost part because we already assumed
some increasing convex costs that were
separable from the payoff that we were
going to get
so for a fixed uh stopping rule
then utility is irrelevant which might
be an application you might actually try
to put into a model because if for
example my boss tells me when i should
quit
then we are able to predict the speed
you're going to do regardless of we know
your utility function or not
on the other hand
if we do have nonlinear utility though
suppose we actually have some risk
aversion then there is going to be some
level where
getting
high enough means i don't want to
experiment anymore that means there is
going to be some satisficing level
that will tell us when to stop
and then there is going to be a boundary
below where the stopping region is a
flat line and the boundary that's
approaching the flat line
so as our maximum increases
this gap is going to slowly decrease
and you will have a
satisficing level with a boundary that
will determine your optimal stopping
in general there is a technical hiccup
in here where the
differential equation for solving the
optimal stopping boundary turns out to
be a double equation of the second kind
which are generally intractable
but if you have
cra utilities then we do provide a
optimal parametric solution in the
online appendix
so
now that we know the speed
and the stopping rule we also need to
know what is the search going to yield
what kind of bagel i'm going to end up
with
and for that we're going back to the
case of risk neutrality
the first thing we can actually show
that the optimal the expected payoff
from optimal retrospective search
can be identified in clause form again
as a function of the drawdowns which are
functions of the optimal speed
that we have identified
what am i doing on time
yes
the
other thing is the expected bagel i find
i can also
find it in close form for the case where
r is equal to zero
uh expected search duration again i can
also find in closed form for r equals to
zero when r is greater than 0 though
unlike the payoff these are only
identified in terms of their joint
moment generating function
so you can do comparative statics with
it but putting them down in a closed
form requires some additional
assumptions on the cost function
now the expected maximum value is kind
of intuitive because brownian motion is
a
martingale
then and we have a drawdown that means
the moment i stop
uh the gap between my
current value and the maximum is exactly
the size of my drawdown so that was easy
enough
that tells you what my expected maximum
is given that my current x is
uh
expected search time is the part where
uh the sigma part is kind of speeding up
our
search duration
tend to mount to
a sigma square in the increase
and then the expected search time of the
draw down to the
speed is
kind of square rated this one is not a
good explanation in terms of intuition
but
that is going back all the
first thing i said about the exponential
arrivals and
that's why you're kind of ending up with
the
low looking a little bit of the
exponential coming in there
there are no general comparative statics
that you can get in terms of costs
because
you can increase marginal cost but keep
the cost level the same we don't know
where it's going to go
but
for
impatience then you do actually have
solid
comparative aesthetics
so now we have the entire result of the
search
everything we might be interested in
hopefully identified in close form in
terms of the parameters of the model
but then we can actually try to apply it
into a contracting model too because now
that we have everything in closed form
let's
try to do that and in fact mineral
exploration
going through a vein is actually done by
a financing firm hiring a mineral
digging company that's not the official
term but
whatever they do
and in the end they'll get some
ratio of the profits and as long as
they're doing the search before they
develop they're being paid a wage
same is true for
well maybe not us but people pro maybe
the computer scientists where they
actually provide patents and the
university is going to get some share of
their
uh proceeds and similarly for art
dealerships i can actually try to give
negative wages i might actually have my
art
shown in some gallery pay for it and in
the end when it's sold from there
there will be actually a commission that
the gallery is going to get
so what we're going to do is an agent is
going to do a retrospective search
principle is the residual residual claim
so we're going to get the rest of the
commission and we're paying the wages
and it's actually
kind of similar to the rules suggested
by aguilon and troll
uh our agent has an outside option of
zero can't create any time for
simplicity for here i'm going to assume
there is no discounting but in fact you
can add discounting to the agent
and it's going to make
almost zero difference
it's this part where this counting is
going to matter because then these two
we only identify in terms of their joint
moment generating functions but you can
actually have an infinitely patient
principle contracting with an inpatient
agent to do their search on behalf of
them
but we know agents problem now all has
changed is
we decreased the costs by w but the
margin hasn't changed
and we're giving them a fixed ratio
alpha which is a a linear transformation
of the utility function as opposed to a
non-linear one
which
just as we have done before since we
assume there is no discounting we can
actually solve the agent's constant
search speed immediately
and also the agent's
optimal stopping boundary but given that
we can actually solve for these two that
means we can actually solve for
these two as well in terms of what the
agent is going to do as a function of
the wages
and what we see is that there is going
to be a constant search speed
that
does not depend on the commission as a
whole so you might give me 90 of my
winnings or 10 percent
it's not going to tell me what my
optimal search speed is
it is going to tell me how fast i'm
going to stop though
on the other hand
uh
the
boundary is going to depend on both of h
and the rate we are getting and this is
also again saying that the optimal
stopping rule is very inherently tied to
the optimal control problem and not the
other way around
and in fact once we solve for these two
though
the principle problem is almost static
this we have now a closed form solution
for this we have a closed form solution
for we're going to find the w and alpha
to maximize what the principal does
which tells us this will be the optimal
speed and the contract that we're going
to pay and i'm almost out of time
so
uh
what we have done is that we ended up
with a retrospective search model
that is with correlated uh observations
and experimentation
and the optimal policy turned out to be
a u-shaped
with a simple stopping boundary
and this drawdown stopping boundary is
actually quite evident in empirical
research of people shopping through
amazon or not where
the simple case of independent price
sampling does not seem to explain what's
going on and make sense if i'm actually
looking for the price of a book
it will be correlated what i see in
amazon to barnes and noble or even
different sellers across amazon
not somebody is going to price a book
for 100 and another for 70. although
that might be the case for the handbook
of brownian motion that i previously
mentioned just because it's out of print
and
the second thing is
the analysis is quite tractable
i mentioned commission search but you
can also think about constraint search
where your principal can in addition put
for example deadlines or they can in
addition say you have a satisficing rule
and everything going through
the agent's part is quite easy
you're just kind of deconstructing
what's going on through
another bit that we have kind of worked
through with quite a bit is where you're
doing a joint search suppose you gather
a group of people they're going to think
about ideas about how to do dynamic
information acquisition and everybody is
pitching in until some of them are going
to decide you know what i'm going to
write a paper on my own or maybe they're
going to say let's jointly write the
paper we're just going to quit from this
conversation and go to a corner and
start scribbling down a model which is
the case we actually searched through
with torque
another beauty of that is it can also
serve for a foundation for a matching
theory where suppose you have pairs that
are going to be doing jointly a search
like this where they are both
contributing speeds and they can
actually quit on their own to get a
maximum
then this gives you in terms of your own
cost functions a complete preference
order on potential pairs you might have
so you can use this as a foundation of
kind of a matching theory for
i don't know professors and phd students
or potential co-authors and get a again
a quite tractable foundation going back
through
only to the cost function
and that's the end thank you so much